예전에는 선거를 보려면 여론조사를 받습니다.
금리를 보려면 연준 발언을 읽었고
전쟁과 휴전을 보려면 뉴스를 따라갔죠.
그런데 지금은 조금 이상한 일이 벌어지고 있습니다.
누가 대선을 이길지, 금리가 언제 내릴지, 휴전이 될지 말지
심지어 어떤 연예인이 어떤 옷을 입을지까지 돈을 걸고 있습니다.
그런데 진짜 이상한 건 그 다음입니다.
이걸 아무도 도박이라고 부르지 않는다는 점입니다.
이제는 이벤트 계약이라 부르고
정보시장이라 부르고 확률을 거래한다고 말합니다.
그러니까 전쟁에 돈을 걸어도 도박을 하는 사람이 아니라
시장에 참여하는 사람처럼 보이게 되는 겁니다.
여기서 질문이 생깁니다.
이건 정말 세상을 더 정확하게 읽는 새로운 시장일까요?
아니면 미국이 세상의 모든 사건에 가격표를 붙이기 시작한 걸까요?
이번 영상에서는 도박이 어떻게 금융이 되었고
왜 사람들은 현실을 바꾸기보다 현실의 결과에 돈을 걸기 시작했는지
그리고 그 순간 시장은 어디까지 이상해질 수 있는지를
자세히 알아보도록 하겠습니다.
그럼 먼저 이 예측시장이라는 게 정확히 뭐냐부터 아주 간단하게 보겠습니다.
생각보다 구조는 단순합니다.
미래에 어떤 사건이 일어날지 말지를 두고 돈을 거는 겁니다.
예를 들어서 올해 안에 금리인회가 있을 것이다.
누가 선거에서 이길 것이다.
휴전이 성사될 것이다 같은 질문이 하나 올라옵니다.
그리고 사람들은 거기에 예 아니면 아니오 둘 중 한쪽에 돈을 겁니다.
여기까지 들으면 그냥 도박처럼 보입니다.
그런데 이걸 시장처럼 보이게 만드는
장치가 하나 있습니다.
바로 가격입니다.
이걸 쉽게 설명해보면 어떤 플랫폼에
올해 안에 금리인회가 있을까라는 질문이 올라왔다고 해보죠.
이 시장에서는 이 질문에 정답을 맞히면
최종적으로 만 원을 받는 티켓이 거래된다고 생각하면 쉽습니다.
그런데 지금 시장 분위기가 가능성이 한 30% 정도 되는 것 같다고 보면
그 티켓 가격은 대략 3천 원쯤에서 형성됩니다.
반대로 사람들이 이건 거의 될 것 같다.
즉 가능성을 70% 정도로 보면 그 티켓 가격은 7천 원쯤으로 올라갑니다.
그리고 나중에 실제로 금리인회가 일어나면
그 티켓은 만 원짜리가 되고
끝내 일어나지 않으면 가치가 0원이 됩니다.
그러니까 여기 들어오는 사람들은
그냥 막연히 결과를 찍는 느낌보다
이게 3천 원짜리일 정도로 가능성이 낮은 일인가?
아니면 사람들이 너무 쉽게 보고 있는 건 아닌가?
이렇게 생각하게 됩니다.
바로 이 지점 때문에 이 시장이 더 그럴 듯해 보이는 겁니다.
겉으로 보면 단순히 결과에 돈을 거는 게 아니라
어떤 사건의 가능성이 너무 싸게 평가되는
지 너무 비싸게 평가되는 지를 따지는 것처럼 보이기 때문입니다.
쉽게 말하면 예전 같으면 그냥 누가 이길까에 돈을 건다는 느낌이었다면
이제는 이 사건의 가능성을 가격으로 사고 판다는 느낌으로 바뀌는 겁니다.
그래서 분위기도 달라집니다.
도박처럼 보이던 행동이 갑자기 거래처럼 보이고
찍기처럼 보이던 행동이 판단처럼 보이고
참가자도 그냥 베팅하는 사람이 아니라
뭔가 시장을 읽는 사람처럼 보이기 시작하는 겁니다.
그래서 많은 사람들이 처음 폴리마켓이나 칼시를 봤을 때
그냥 옵션 거래 같은 느낌을 받습니다.
직관적으로 보면 미래에 벌어질 일에 대해 가격이 붙고
그 가격이 기대와 확률을 반영하고
맞으면 수익이 나고 틀리면 손실을 보는 구조라서 비슷해 보이는 겁니다.
하지만 완전히 같은 건 아닙니다.
옵션은 기본적으로 주식이나 지수 같은 기초 자산의 가격 움직임을 바탕으로 만들어진
표준화된 파생 상품입니다.
반면 예측 시장은 특정 자산의 가격이 아니라
어떤 사건이 일어나느냐 아니냐 자체를 거래 대상으로 삼습니다.
삼성전자 주가가 오를지 내릴지를 놓고 정교하게 설계된 옵션과
전쟁이 멈출지 선거에서 누가 이길 지를 두고
예 아니어로 돈을 거는 시장은 분명히 다르다는 겁니다.
그런데 중요한 건 그 차이보다도 이 구조가 사람들에게 어떤 인상을 주느냐입니다.
차트가 있고 숫자가 있고 가격이 실시간으로 움직이고
사람들이 거기에 들어와서 사고 팔기 시작하는 순간
본질은 그대로인데 겉모습은 완전히 달라집니다.
도박은 갑자기 정보가 되어집니다.
배팅은 갑자기 거래가 되고 판 또는 갑자기 확률 가격처럼 보이게 됩니다.
바로 이 지점에서 예측 시장 플랫폼들은
자신들을 현실을 더 정확하게 읽어내는 시장이라고 설명합니다.
사람은 말을 할 때보다 돈을 걸 때 훨씬 더 솔직해진다는 겁니다.
여론조사에서는 희망을 말할 수 있지만 돈이 걸리면
결국 실제로 일어날 것 같은 쪽에 배팅하게 된다는 거죠.
그래서 이들은 전문가의 말이나 흔들리는 여론조사보다
실제 돈이 들어간 가격이 더 적은 것입니다.
그래서 이들은 전문가의 말이나 흔들리는 여론조사보다 실제 돈이 들어간 가격이 더 적은 것입니다.
이 말이 그럴듯하게 들리는 이유도 분명합니다.
세상은 늘 불확실하고 사람들은 언제나
그래서 결국 어떻게 될 건데를 알고 싶어합니다.
그런데 뉴스는 해석이 갈리고 전문가는 서로 말이 다르고
여론조사는 항상 엎치락뒤치락입니다.
바로 그때 시장 가격 하나가 떠버리면
사람들은 거기서 결론을 보고 싶어합니다.
특히 선거처럼 불확실성이 큰 이벤트일수록 더 그렇습니다.
하지만 문제는 여기서 시작됩니다.
더 정확한 숫자가 나온다는 것과 더 공정한 시장이라는 것은 전혀 다른 이야기입니다.
예측 시장은 겉으로는 모두에게 열려있는 시장처럼 보이지만
실제로는 적은 돈으로도 가격이 흔들릴 수 있고
누군가는 남들보다 먼저 정보를 알 수도 있습니다.
그렇다면 일반 참여자는 처음부터 같은 출발선에 서 있는 게 아닙니다.
즉 이 시장은 더 정확해 보일 수는 있어도 더 공정하다고 말하기는 어렵다는 겁니다.
그런데 여기서 더 중요한 건
미국에서 이런 시장이 제도권 문턱까지 올라오게 되었냐는 점입니다.
원래 미국의 CFTC 그러니까 상품선물거래위원회는
밀, 면화, 농산물, 원자재 같은 실물경제 관련 선물시장을 감독하던 기간이었습니다.
목적도 분명했죠.
농부와 기업이 가격변동의 위험을 줄일 수 있게 두고
시장이 불법 도박판으로 흐르지 않게 관리하는 것이었습니다.
그런데 시간이 지나면서 시장은 금류와 주가지수로 넓어졌고
나중에는 비트코인 같은 더 추상적인 시장으로 이루어졌습니다.
결국 실물경제의 위험을 관리하려고 만든 제도가
점점 더 추상적이고 투기적인 영역까지 포괄하게 된 끝에서
나온 결과물이라는 겁니다.
그리고 바로 그 변화 위에 지금 시대의 불안이 겹쳐졌습니다.
열심히 저축해도 따라잡기 어렵고
집을 사는 길도 멀어 보이고 꾸준히 모으는 방식으로는
인생이 잘 풀릴 것 같지 않다는 패배감이 커졌습니다.
예전에는 그 불안이 암호화폐로 몰렸다면
이제는 그 일부가
예측시장으로 옮겨온 겁니다.
주식은 공부가 필요하고 부동산은 돈이 많이 들고
장기투자는 시간이 필요합니다.
반면 예측시장은 훨씬 빠릅니다.
누가 이길지 언제 발표가 날지 휴전이 될지 말지를 두고
지금 당장 베팅하면 되니까요.
그래도 여기서 예측시장의 장점을 하나 짚고 넘어가야겠죠.
보통 스포츠 도박 사이트는 사이트가 이용자와 사실상
맞붙는 구조인 경우가 많았습니다.
그러니까 내가 계속 이기면 그 사이트 입장에서는 손해가 커져서
커지겠죠.
그래서 어떤 곳은 잘 맞히는 사람의 베팅한도를 줄이거나
아예 계정을 막아버리기도 합니다.
반면 예측시장은 보통 사용자들끼리 반대 포지션을 연결해주고
수수료를 받는 구조를 강조합니다.
그래서 겉으로는 더 공정해 보일 수 있습니다.
하지만 문제는 그렇게 이기는 사람이 대체 누구냐는 겁니다.
일반 개인이 꾸준히 이길 가능성은 높지 않습니다.
더 빠른 정보, 더 많은 자본, 더 정교한 계산을 가진 쪽이 유리합니다.
결국 누구나 들어갈 수 있는
시장과 누구에게나 유리한 시장은 전혀 다르다는 얘기입니다.
이번 영상에서 중요한 건 미국에 신기한 예측 사이트가 있다는 이야기가 아닙니다.
더 중요한 건 사람들이 이제 현실을 이해하려기보다
그 결과에 먼저 돈을 걸기 시작했다는 점입니다.
정치가 흔들리면 누가 이길지부터 보고
전쟁이 터지면 왜 벌어졌는지 보다 언제 끝날지에 돈이 몰리고
금리가 움직이면 그 배경보다 언제 내릴지 수차부터 확인합니다.
쉽게 말해서
세상이
점점 뉴스의 대상이 아니라
베팅의 대상이 되어가고 있는 겁니다.
이쯤에서 더 본질적인 질문을 던져보죠.
왜 우리는 현실을 바꾸는 것보다
그 현실에 먼저 가격을 붙이는 데 더 익숙해졌을까?
예측 시장은 지금 시대가 어디로 가고 있는지를
가장 잘 보여주는 사례일 뿐입니다.
이름은 바뀌었지만 본질은 그대로입니다.
도박은 사라진 게 아니라 투자처럼 보이게 바뀌었을 뿐입니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.